I FELT LIKE
I PLAYED THAT EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND SHE STABBED ME
IN THE HEAD.
- WHAT CAN I SAY?
ANOTHER VALENTINE'S DAY
WITH MY BOYS,
EATING HEART-SHAPED PIZZA
FROM RANCHO CUCAPIZZA.
YUMMY.
- OH!
- GUYS, WE SHOULD BE EATING
RANCHO CUCA-PENOCHE.
- MM-HMM.
- AND WE DID NOT REHEARSE
THAT LISA LOEB SONG
FOR FIVE HOURS
NOT TO SERENADE
OUR VALENTINE'S DAY DATES,
DUDES.
- THIS IS MAKING ME SAD
AND I HATE BEING SAD.
LET'S GO DO SOMETHING UN-SAD.
LIKE WATCHING PORNOG TOGETHER
ON THE BIG SCREEN.
- THAT SOUNDS AWESOME.
- NO! DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND?
PORNO'S THE REASON WE DON'T KNOW
HOW TO TALK TO GIRLS.
- WHAT?
- PORNOG...
- THANK YOU.
- IS THE REASON WE DON'T KNOW
HOW TO TALK TO GIRLS ANYMORE.
OKAY, IT'S MELTED OUR BRAINS
INTO...
PORN JUICE OR SOMETHING,
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE GOT TO MEET
REAL CHICKS
OR ELSE WE'RE NEVER
GONNA BE REAL MEN.
- OKAY, SURE.
BUT WHERE ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO MEET REAL CHICKS
WITH 48 HOURS
UNTIL THE BIG DAY?
[computer key clacks]
- REALCHIXXXCHAT.COM.
- WEBCAM GIRLS?
COME ON.
THIS IS PORNOG, RIGHT?
- MM-MM.
- THESE ARE REAL GIRLS
THAT HAPPEN TO BE ONLINE, RIGHT?
LOOKING FOR REAL GUYS LIKE US
IN THE REAL WORLD.
- YEAH, THEY'RE REAL CHICKS,
THEY'RE JUST SITTING THERE.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE EATING FOOD,
SOMETIMES THEY'RE MASTURBATING.